Hey, it's-
Hello!
Wow! Look at selection. Click the right-
Oh.
Got it!
Hey, look at me! I'm running everybody!
Don't mind me! Just walking down the street. Not a problem.  "Don't make me chase you!" Don't make me chase you!
I'm gonna getcha! Stop right there. Oh, good thing you're here.
Oh.
Got you now, motherfucker!
Oh no.
Where am I?
My look. Oh, it's me. "Look's like we've got the place to ourselves..."
No, no, no, please grow-. Hold the grip or trigger to make a fist.
Ohhh.
Punch by extending your arm, making contact when opening appears... Right click. Okay.
You can also slap an opponent with an open hand.
Block by raising your arms
What are you doing? Ah.
Oh, okay. "Uniform makes you feel tough, doesn't it?" I-I see how it is.
You got nice... thighs!
If I massage you... will you stop?
Will you stop hurting me?
Aw, you don't like that?!
Huh?!
I slap your knee!
Ah, slap, aha!
Works every time, baby.
I found your weakness.
Tickle, tickle!
"Are you fighting, or flirting?"
I'm definitely flirting.
Alright, enough games.
"Picked the wrong day to fuck with me."
Don't make me hit you again!
Don't make me!
Swedish! Slap! Swedish! Slap!
Don't make me do it- slap, slap, slap, slap!
Don't make me- slapslapslapslap!
Slap left!
I slap you!
Huaaaaaah!
Slap, slap!
Huaaaaaaaaaah!
Slap, slap slap! Slap! Oh, whatchu want boy?!
You want more?!
Slap! You want more of the slap?!
Slap! Raaa-ta-ta-da-ta! Bah! Bah!
Block you, slap!
"Are you fighting, or flirting?"
Hey, hey- hey, hey.
Slap! Slap- buh! Sla-buh.
Woaah- buh!
Bah, bah!
Dick punch!
Oh, God.
"How you doing, Wendell?
"Your parole officer's feeling lonely. He's got a hole in his life for an asshole like you."
You got a hole in- in your pants now, boy.
"Watch your head. This hump will be back in the iron hotel by tomorrow night."
"Nice work." Oh, I know. "You run track in high school?" No, but I ran the slap Club
We slap bitches!
All the time.
What is this?
"All units to 211 in progress. Shots fired at West Lake savings and loan-"
Oh, you want me to get in the car?
Excuse me?
I don't even have a driving license.
Well, I guess I better get in the car. "We'll take that. Only a couple blocks from here."
Okay.
Hey, hey, Monika! Hey to you, Monika!
Alright.
"14 Adam, calling KPGL. We'll handle the 211."
"Rodger that, 14 Adam. Be advised, suspects are armed-"
Don't be scared.
Don't be scared. "Roger, KGPL. 14 Adam enroute." Are you scared?
Are you scared?
"Take the next right!"
I will... I will take the next right.
Will you talk to me like that again? Then you will face the slap!
"Take the next right!"
What did I- dah!
Okay.
Don't worry. Let's go.
Oh! We're going the wrong- oh.
Sorry. "Take the next left."
Woah!
Next left. Got it.
Do you fear it? "Through the next intersection!" Now tell me something... do you fear dying?
Are you scared of dying?
"No, no, no! You did not just do that!" I didn't do nothing! You're stressing me out, man.
I am trying to drive like a perfect gentleman, oh.
Oh, shit. It's a robbery
Wait, that's me!
Oh, hell yeah!
Oh god. I'm a lil scared. I've never done this before.
I don't know what I thought would happen...
Motherfucka!
"Stay down!" Stay down, biiiiitch. What do I do? I'm so scared.
My power move. "Stay in cover!"
What the fuck is this? What are you doing? I'm moving in! I'm moving in, guys!
Ay! Got 'em.
Don't fucking tell me what to do.
He fell for the old hay trick laptop
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about what's going on over here
Hey, Johnny, I think I found a clue
Crawl a kill insects brain maybe
Excuse me workers
Please step aside. We're basically working
This is spooky I'm super scared right now Jesus
Cole come take a look at the I see it dude I see her put him up against the wall and whose brains out
Damnable way to go
Dude, I don't know about this blood matter. How you go. This is this is a bit scary. Oh get all deep only built
Let's keep going two rounds fired and instead of dropping it down a drain our shooter voices it up here interesting guy
We should follow up on this now before the perp tries to leave town, it's fired twice yes, I see
I'll draw I'll draw a picture of the gun
Hey, just Phelps undone, can you tell us anything about this gun Smith & Wesson Model?
27 registered Magnum chambered for 357 Hey they complete it with programs same gun used by General Patton
You're not suggesting he's the owner no no no no you seem to know a lot about your weapon
Let me do the talking sold it you know this piece will stop a rhino
These babies oh my god. That's a special order
Here's my Smith & Wesson order book
Okay, let's see here pearl grips. Cold you see it on a real collectors. I don't like your attitude. Sorry
I can't help you more. Hey. We're in luck Errol Schroeder
203 southwest street ordered the gun in February 46
Thanks, you've been a big help any time. Thank you very much. Happy to help out the LAPD you're doing a great job
Thank you. I really my affair, but I hope you catch whoever you're looking for are these authentic
Are these authentic ducks?
How much how much for them please oh?
My god, okay?? Oh!
Sorry that wasn't me I swear..
Stop that stop that!!
You fucking bitch you!
You hey you hey you??
Do you know shredding here's his phone number
Don't make me
Is that milk now, I haven't had a nice bottle of milk and forever
Judge
Open up its the popo. What are you guys? Whoa hey? I'm officer Cole Phelps. Don't mind me Verdun bullshit division
You're the owner of a Smith & Wesson Model 27 nickel-plated with pearl grips. I might be
What of it, then you'll be surprised to know that scooter Payton was murdered tonight with your gun you're out of your mind
Scooter he works for me. They have that gun here in my drawer
You're under arrest Schroeder come in my way. You're not taking me down for this. Oh oh
It's very sad. No. It's sound again. Oh
Sweetie slap maced
Come wake up
Come come I said oh you got you're gonna cry huh you gonna crap you're gonna crack. You're gonna. Cry. Are you gonna crack?
This is how a fire in Sweden this is how the Vikings fire?
Oh my god, LAPD LAPD cleared the body, please please has anyone called an ambulance
We've called an ambulance and the police, but I'm afraid he's dead
What did you see
The fuck up
oh
Don't make me
Hey, hey look at this look at this don't make me
Now tell me what you saw
I
Got nothing on this guy hey
Hey mama
Hey, mama
Don't worry. Don't worry. It's gonna be okay, huh?
Then just tell me what you suppose
Yeah, no. I'm not gonna like you're probably gonna go many years
Enterprise are you just staring at me like that because I mean nothing wrong. Oh, yes, what you think you have
Your can I go to jail you're gonna go to jail
You're gonna go in for a very long
But don't worry. Don't worry
If Papa boots can get one of those shoots in size 42
Hey, why are you just staring at me like not worried I've done nothing I'm officer Phelps miss I'm here about the shooting
I'm here about the show do you know the victim -?
It wasn't my boss yes, don't worry, it's mr.. Gage
Not mr. Burrage don't you are I?
Was in a store when mr. Gage
my boss bursts in yelling that I'm late on my lunch and we came back I
was angry I
walked in front yes, of course I
Heard shots mm-hmm I turned and saw mr.. Gage fall. Oh
Nice that's awful
And don't know who shot gage or why no officer
That's truth my man is dead miss : and that's a criminal offense to lie to a police officer. I'll take you downtown get out
Get out right now
alright, check the dumpster
Look at that, huh? You didn't see- are you kidding me?
"Any ideas?" "Looks like there's something in this trash can." I already found it!
"Operator, give me dispatch."
"Phelps badge 12 47."
"Messages, please."
"Thanks for your help."
Grabbed the gun right? You think something would happen.
But nothing happens... is this glitched out, or?
"Wake-up call!" I found the- "Shell casings... these look like thirty twos."
Okay, so now I found a gun. Okay, I get it.
No, I guess the gun still isn't interesting. Got it. Let's go
He's fine, don't worry about him. I want you to know that I loved you.
Really thought we would be together forever... You were always my brother.
Hey wait no no no don't
Come back here, Baldy!
You forgot your hat! Oh, oh oh!
How did I knock him over?
You can just run into people!
I'm so sorry, so sorry, so sorry, so sorry!